تسأل أه عائشة ما هي الأمراض الأخرى التي يمكن أن تتحول إلى جائحة وكيف يمكننا تحسين استجابتنا للوباء بقدر ما تعرف مسببات الأمراض الأخرى التي يمكن أن تصبح وباءً ، إنها قائمة طويلة من الأشياء ولكن كقاعدة عامة أنت ' إعادة النظر في فيروسات الجهاز التنفسي أكثر من مسببات الأمراض التي قد تنتقل عن طريق البعوض على سبيل المثال لأنه يمكنك التعامل مع ناقل البعوض ربما ولكن إذا بدأ فيروس تنفسي مثل فيروس الأنفلونزا أو فيروس كورونا مثل هذا في الانتقال إلى حد كبير وقاتل هؤلاء. هي حقًا مكونات للوباء ، فهناك العديد من الطرق التي يمكننا من خلالها الاستعداد بدءًا من الفكرة الأساسية للغاية المتمثلة في تحديد مسببات الأمراض المحتملة التي تقفز من الحيوانات إلى البشر في هذا المستوى لتكون قادرًا على تحديد هؤلاء مبكرًا مع التأكد من أن لديك أنظمة الصحة العامة الجيدة المطبقة بحيث عندما يظهر الناس مرضى في مستشفى أو عيادة بشيء غير عادي يمكن أن يتعرضوا على الفور  حددت أن
الفيروس يمكن
تسلسله ويمكننا أن نبدأ حتى في التفكير في
صنع علاجات ولقاحات في وقت مبكر جدًا ،
هناك الكثير من الطرق لتصبح
دليلًا على الجائحة
كما أخبرني العديد من خبراء الصحة العامة ،
لكن هذا مثال على اثنين
منهم يحاولان حقًا  وقائيًا
من حيث التفكير في هذا الوباء ،
يسأل أندرو عن مدى احتمالية أن تصبح الأقنعة
هي القاعدة خلال فصل
الشتاء جيدًا.أندرو الثاني لا أعرف أنك تعلم
أنه أمر مضحك ،
فأنا أنظر كثيرًا مما حدث في هونغ
كونغ على سبيل المثال بعد
العديد من البلدان في آسيا هي دول ترتدي الأقنعة
وقد تطورت تلك الثقافة
لأسباب مختلفة ولكن في
هونغ كونغ
كان هذا المكان الذي تضرر
بشدة من السارس هذا في عام 2003 2004
لم يكونوا في الحقيقة يرتدون القناع
قبل ذلك
الآسيوي الآخر  البلدان كانت ولكن ليس
كثيرًا في هونغ كونغ
بسبب ما حدث مع السارس ،
أعتقد أنها
أصبحت أكثر من
بلد متنكر وبمجرد أن بدأ هذا الوباء
بدأت شركة Take root hong kong على الفور في
تنفيذ الأقنعة
وكانت الثقافة تقبل ذلك لدرجة أن
الناس فعلوا ذلك على
الفور تقريبًا وربما ساعدت كثيرًا أعتقد
أنه سيكون هناك أقنعة في هذا
البلد ، لم نكن حقًا دولة تنمو بشكل كبير على ما
أعتقد '  سنرى
الكثير من ذلك
الآن إلى الأبد ، كما تعلم ، أعني أنه
في أشهر الشتاء عندما
ينتشر فيروس الإنفلونزا ، قد ترى
الكثير من
الأقنعة ونعلم أنها يمكن أن تكون فعالة
لأنه بقدر ما تساعد الأقنعة
الأشخاص الذين  كانوا يرتدون أقنعة حصلوا على
حماية ضد مرض كوفيد وساعدوا في
حماية الآخرين
من فيروس كورونا ، كما أدى ذلك إلى خفض أعداد الإنفلونزا
أيضًا ،
لذا أعتقد أننا سنشهد
تحولًا سلوكيًا لن يكون
منتشرًا على نطاق واسع ولا أعتقد ذلك ولكنك
سترى الناس  يرتدي الأقنعة
ومن المحتمل أن يرتفع في الأوقات
التي تنتشر فيها فيروسات الجهاز التنفسي